oh qu'il est beau le chaton mais
évidemment ce n'est plus un jeunot
construit essentiellement sous charles
de 8 à la fin du xvème siècle le domaine
royal d'amboise à plus de 500 ans il a
donc besoin comme tous les joyaux du val
de loire alentours de soins constants et
appropriée en ce moment c'est le lieu où
reposent les restes présumés d'un très
grand architecte qui est l'objet d'une
attention particulière
alors nous ne trouvons maintenant dans
la chapelle saint-hubert cette chapelle
qui abrite les restes de léonard de
vinci ce qui a caractérisé cette frise
qui a été sculptée à même le tuffeau
cette pierre de la région et qui est
composé comme une dentelle sur les
corniches de l'édifice
l'opération de rénovation a débuté à
l'automne et va durer deux ans pour
reprendre totalement la charpente et
dépoussiéré l'ensemble seules des
entreprises dûment reconnue par le
ministère de culture peuvent effectuer
ce travail d'où la facture avoisinant 2
millions 500 mille euros ce sont des
mises en oeuvre très durable par les
techniques traditionnelles par les
matériaux par une entité cnic je dirais
ça que la technique et dans la mise en
oeuvre manuelle elle n'est pas dans la
technicité des choses je voulais donc
les matériaux eux mêmes sont très
durable et finalement une toiture comme
celle que l'on va restaurer dure 120 140
ans qui
une facture finalement presque
raisonnable au regard de la qualité de
la rénovation et du coût d'entretien
habituels du château d'amboise
en règle générale on en a pour à peu
près cinq cent mille euros par an pour
entretenir un morceau de remparts sur un
monument historique très historique
comme celui d'amboise nous avons en
général toujours un gros chantier tous
les trois ans
à à prévoir cette fois le coville a du
bon car l'état finance 84% du chantier
via le plan de relance et il y aura un
retour sur investissement en période
normale ce château accueille près de 450
mille visiteurs par an
[Musique]